yeah welcome to the second video of
today now with blackened why does a feed
a master from the United States and he
played see form okay let's um let's go
if I've
yeah I don't usually play 5 10 or but
for the sake of variety also i'm not
trying this okay i'm trying to play some
kind of reversed on comp realtek which
actually am it's quite unreasonable
option for black especially am the
bishop get some developed to be four
yes 95 I think I even played this as
wide some time ago and I remember that I
was somewhat surprised that it didn't
really lead to anything let's hope this
applies to this game as well okay I
could what could black do some are you
need to get rid of this night okay I
could to capture immediately I could
play d6 one problem here for white maybe
as some you you cannot really play
Knight f3 because then then i would i
would take here so maybe d6 first but I
could also consider 97 with the idea of
playing maybe c6 even at some point ok
let's go 26 first don't want to spend
too much time
interesting
yeah maybe one idea here is let's say
I'd take here you captured with the pawn
i go to e7 that maybe it's got something
like 9 35 36 some point and also f4
becomes an option here on normal a
normal move also would be 97 just to
play c6 get rid of the night ok let's um
let's play this don't spend too much
time
yeah I guess you should just take on f6
now maybe take on f6 and then no and
then yeah this is a surprising choice i
get i was expecting taking on f6 and
then f4 and now i'm asking myself from
if I don't is there some some direct way
to to play here maybe okay capture let's
capture this first I have my doubts
about this here what why did I was
thinking about f4 but now I'm seeing
that maybe he can he can play 95 then
but but let's consider f4 let's let's
check first if he takes on f4 I would I
think be able to take on h3 Bishop takes
and then night h5 this is this is
interesting getting getting the Queen
over to h4 and Knight to f4 and so on
this is some
interesting but on f4 of course you
could also play and play simple chess
with 95 still I like the smooth not
shown yeah let's let's go
didn't invest much time in this
surprising
yeah maybe it is just maybe I'm just
playing bad news but yeah of course if i
take here he's got this this option of
checking here but
haha
yeah of course I'm not delivering made
immediately or something let's say p.m.
he could check on his six if he wants to
maybe this is shine yeah okay let's play
this first and now he could he could
take on e5 I guess he also should take
only five then neither for the threatens
between g5 mate so he needs to play em
play King King to h1 and then then the
sum then I could at least play Queen
tonight x e6 and take on e5 I'll always
get the c6 porn back and I think it sets
playable for black at least hmm I take
here I think I'm threatening really a
three or taught what thoughts I'm
irritated
yeah okay let's do this first
I think it's it's really looking
dangerous for her white isn't it what
about Queen h4 now then the the normal
move for white would be something like
rook g1 but I can just take III then and
f2 is hanging on let's say you kept us
with the porn i play rook f2 and resins
so he doesn't have this move and it just
looks looks like the normal way to
proceed ah Alfred yeah I will not accept
the draw here this is some I think just
just good for black you for
okay what now FF three
f3 rook g1 ruka for piling up here get
get all the pieces over them
it's not not the only only attractive
option but ok let's get going I'm close
to delivering may tiem with Quinn takes
rook chief rook edge fraud would be made
except for the fact that this Bishop can
can still interpose so 11 funny idea
actually would be rookie aid and capture
only six so maybe this is even a good
next move and we cannot do much anyway
think maybe you can play a play rock g3
Rock g3
yeah Ruby three would have been an idea
i think
okay let's play place to put here and
threaten this maybe this should have
looked deeper here but
yeah it's somewhat of a cheap trick that
have to admit that okay I cannot take on
e6 now because of the back rank of
course it's a very cheeky of him to to
capture to capture on a seven
I don't see something i don't see
something directly crushing here
Becca rank is really annoying
very very difficult maybe I should play
b6 and trying to somehow or play h6 then
threaten this hmm come on
I don't understand anything here why can
I just take here and give checkmate or
did you just overlook this yeah
sometimes the cheap tricks are working
Chuck what checkmate yeah mysterious
game don't didn't understand at all what
he was doing there he should at least
simply amazing to basically capture this
without much thinking and then on H
sticks which is really completely like
telephoning my intentions here and it
just played rukka one rookie eight even
after you create it's completely obvious
that i want to take on e6 otherwise this
move is completely useless so what was
he thinking that I was just I don't know
he okay yeah he should of course just
yeah can you do something to prevent
this yeah well Rock g3 I can catch on
the g3 and play Queen h3 now group AF
one was a stupid move somewhat stupid
move anyway so checkmate yeah ok well
nice mate and this was a second game for
today and I still haven't had breakfast
yet so take a break now and maybe do one
or two games more later